now to start off today
i want everyone in here to close their
eyes now think about the first thing
that you saw this morning when you
opened your eyes
you know was it that stain on your
ceiling that you keep putting off
cleaning
was it your partner's face
or your child jumping on top of you
was the morning rays of the sun just
creeping in through the blinds that
mixture of pink orange and yellow that
signifies the start of a new day
keep your eyes shut just for a moment
longer
and imagine waking up now but instead of
those beautiful images all you could see
is what you're seeing right now
darkness
those thoughts those images of the first
thing you saw this morning being exactly
what it is now
just a memory
an image conjured by your brain
from your past
now open your eyes
when i ask people what the one sense
that they couldn't live without is most
will immediately say their sight and you
can understand why that is i mean our
vision and what we see play such an
integral role into how we perceive the
world around us
just look at how much we spend on
buildings on parks on architecture on
things just to please our visual sense
but what if we can't see
what if we lose this gift
what if slowly but surely your visual
field looks something
like this
well this is exactly what happens in
age-related macular degeneration or amd
this disease is the leading cause of
blindness in the developed world
this disease affects one in seven new
zealanders over the age of 50 and yet
the most common form of this disease
has no cure
amd
is a serious problem
but we think we have something that may
just be the solution these tiny
molecules called microrna that are
incredibly powerful gene regulators but
first let's talk a little bit about how
we actually see
now
that is just a stunning structure isn't
it
i mean i could stare at it forever which
is ironic because that's what allows me
to do so
this is a retina this is the thing that
allows us to absorb light bouncing off
of objects this is the thing that allows
us to define shapes define edges this is
what allows us to see
it lines the back of the eye and is
multi-layered with each layer containing
cells with its own respective role now
the cell type i want you to know about
today are photoreceptors if you break
down the word you can figure out what
they mean photo meaning light
and receptors or something that receives
so they receive the light
so when the light comes into our eye
it's received by these cells and through
a series of processes begins to convert
it into an electrical signal that is in
sent to the brain eventually
this will form an image
this is the first step to our vision to
everything we see to you looking at me
right now
now there's a specialized region within
the retzer known as the macula it's
approximately five millimeters in
diameter
and houses another even more specialized
region known as the fovea
now when the light comes into our eye
it's concentrated to focus on this
region of the retina
it's responsible for pretty much all of
our useful day-to-day vision from our
color perception to our high visual
detail to our central vision all of this
mediated by this tiny region
it's also the region where your
photoreceptors begin to die
if you have amd
in fact a 1.5 millimeter lesion in this
area which is approximately the
thickness of a credit card
will render you legally blind
unfortunately amd is an incredibly
complex disease and what this means is
if you try and block a single thing
leading to the disease it's very likely
that something else will just come and
take its place
whether that be well established causes
such as inflammation or oxidative stress
or things we just don't even know about
yet
it's the same issue that faces
researchers looking into treatments for
all kinds of neurodegenerative diseases
such as alzheimer's or parkinson's
but what if we could find one therapy
that could treat
multiple causes
you know what if we could
get to the root
of the disease well maybe we can but to
get there we need to understand just a
little bit about genetics
now
some of you may be familiar with famous
watson crick and wilkins who in many
ways were the pioneers of dna as we know
it
i'm sure a lot of you will also be
familiar with steven spielberg's epic
movie jurassic park
remember that scene they have a
preserved mosquito with dinosaurs blood
in it and they use that to create new
dinosaurs and probably the coolest yet
most dangerous theme park of all time
a lot of you probably scoffed at that
idea but in some ways genetically
speaking
it's actually true
as francis crick said
dna makes rna
rna makes protein and protein
makes us
this is the central dogma of genetics
you can think of dna as the code coding
for just about everything about us it's
what makes us human and not a monkey a
rat or dog it's what makes us unique
individuals it's what makes us who we
are but it is just the code
so without the other components of the
central dogma it's just going to sit
there like a book waiting to be read
knowledge from this book just waiting to
be implemented
now your rna are your messengers
responsible for bringing some of that
code and telling ourselves okay this is
what needs to be produced right now
then the protein that's made is your
functional component or your workers if
you will
you can actually think of this central
dogma as swedish flat pack furniture
giants ikea
think of the ikea warehouse as your dna
containing all the code all the
instructions for how these pieces of
furniture will be made but nothing
is actually assembled yet
if you choose what you need and you come
out of the warehouse with a set of
instructions for your furniture this set
of instructions is your rna
copies and copies of these instructions
leaving the warehouse telling us of
exactly how we assemble these pieces of
furniture
then the fully functional furniture
whether it be your wardrobe or a couch
that's your protein all assembled ready
to do what they need to do
dna makes rna
rna makes protein and protein makes us
now when we talk about a standard gene
therapy you're often looking at a single
target
so gene therapies are fantastic for
diseases that can be attributed to a
single gene mutation or single root
cause but for disease like amd where
there's multiple possible causes
it's just not as useful at this point in
time
but
there's another type of rna called
microrna
and instead of coding for the creation
of protein these micro rna can actually
control
which rna are being read
they are incredibly powerful molecules
with a single micro rna having the
ability to control up to 200 different
targets and what is known as negative
regulation
but this means that when it binds to an
rna it stops it from being red
and the protein
from being produced
so let's go back to ikea
imagine micro rna as an officer
roaming the car park of ikea checking
everything that's coming out of the
warehouse for a particular type of
furniture now notice i say type
this is what i mean by a pathway
so let's say we're suffering from a
coffee table epidemic where people are
just cluttering their living rooms with
coffee tables upon coffee tables on
coffee tables for no apparent reason
now ikea will sell hundreds of different
kinds of coffee tables but they're all
still coffee tables serving the same
general function
a microni office will recognize this and
specifically get rid of all coffee table
instructions
doesn't matter the shape the size or the
color if it's a coffee table
the instructions will no longer be red
and it will no longer be assembled
this is how micro rna work
they can regulate multiple genes from
the same pathway and this is why they
are so powerful because we now have the
ability
to control an entire pathway rather than
a single gene on it
microni have only really been discovered
since the turn of the century and yet
there are already multiple
microrna-based therapeutics in clinical
trials for complex diseases such as
cancer
this shows their potential this shows
their rapidness in going from the lab
bench to the clinical bedside
so let's recap
we have an incredibly complex disease
known as age-related macular
degeneration or amd a disease that
affects your central vision with the
most common form having no known cure or
treatment
we have dna code that makes us us we
have rna messengers for the creation of
protein and then we have microrna
controllers of this process
so in order to decide which mica rna
might be effective in amd
we used a technique that allowed us to
figure out all of the active microrna in
the retina and the targets they're
controlling
using this technique we found this a
particular microrna known as microrna
124
our hero of the story
one two four was far and wide the most
abundant and active micro rna that we
found in the retina it's definitely
playing a role in fact
we found that it's playing an
anti-inflammatory role
this is one of the pathways that it acts
on
so controls the production of highly
inflammatory molecules when the retina
gets too stressed
124 is strong
it's a great worker
helps the greater good exactly
like a hero should
so we looked in the retinas of amd
patients
and what we found was this
one two four stained and red
was completely absent from the central
retina of amd patients when compared to
a healthy individual
completely
remember the part of your retina
responsible for pretty much all of our
useful vision well
one two four
is missing there
and this is what we think is happening
one two four is the most active microrna
in the retina meaning that it's working
a lot even in a diseased state fighting
off danger molecules inflammatory
molecules that will cause even more harm
now the retina recognizes this and
activates more and more of our one to
four however
the retina eventually gets overwhelmed
tragically our heroes can no longer keep
fighting and start dying off to the
point where they are completely absent
exactly like we see
in those amd patients
the enemies keep coming one two four
though
no more
missing in action
and as a consequence our retina suffers
our vision
suffers
so in a study we published last year we
supplemented one to four to animals that
have undergone retinal damage
and through an injection of these
molecules into the eye what we saw was
that animals receiving the treatment had
better retinal function
had less photoreceptor cell death and
had less inflammation
now these are preliminary experiments
but a very promising start at that
our next step is to carefully analyze
all of the targets that this 124 acts to
control
and we're also particularly interested
in how it is that these microrna travel
in the retina as a form of communication
between cells now what do i mean by this
well we've been mainly focused on
photoreceptors
but the retina is an interconnected
network with every cell contributing to
its overall function
in this same study
we found that one two four moves from
the photoreceptor cells to another cell
type but only
after the retina is damaged
too often we kind of look at what's
happening in the cells completely
forgetting there's actually space in
between them so if we can harness this
and discover how and why these mic rna
move between cells then we can engineer
a deliverable vehicle to transport the
micro rna that we want
exactly
where we want it
i want everyone to have a look at this
image again
imagine living the rest of your life
with vision like this
it's next time you're with your loved
ones
study their faces
they're every feature
next time you wake up in the morning pay
attention to every single detail of what
you're seeing
use that gift of sight
and cherish these memories
because as i said one in seven of you
will lose this ability if nothing is
done about this disease
with an aging demographic in current
times our society seems to be very
concerned about living longer and
extending our lifespan
but this is so
wrong
trust me when i say this
longevity
is not the answer
quality
is the answer
it's not about
yeah it's not about how long we can live
no
it's about how long we can live
well and with the use of microrna our
hope and our goal
is that for millions of people
this image
can become clearer
for longer
thank you
[Applause]